olá pessoal eu agradeço a proibir
conversando com vocês hoje agradeço o
convite que possibilitou isso vou
procurar conversar com vocês sobre
aspectos que são de fato muito
importante na minha vida pessoal para
minha vida profissional e acredito ter
muito a ver com vocês também já que a
gente vai falar de saúde alberto falou
na questão de bem estar acima de tudo e
bem estar não somente físico mas mental
social então vamos falar o que nos
interessa é abordar temas que eu venho
vivenciando a minha vida profissional na
minha vida de médico de professor de
quem se propõe a fazer uma pesquisa
sobre isso e vou começar contando uma
história pra vocês que não era minha
história do de um advogado de são paulo
sobre o lixo pollini que veio
literalmente para morrer em
florianópolis já que tem uma doença
grave uma cardiopatia grave é teve fato
passou por procedimentos
intervencionista e cirurgia cardíaca
angioplastia e depois de várias
complicações
quero entender a ele que não tinha uma
chance com o tratamento que existe em
são paulo e são paulo é um grande centro
na medicina brasileira está sendo
tratado num centro de cardiologia de
referência importante para nós fizemos
tudo que podíamos fazer por você quiser
entender que iria morrer em seis meses e
tanto já que estava com insuficiência
cardíaca que estava limitando muito a
vida deles tinha falta de ampla qualquer
coisa que fizesse na vida andava um
pouquinho pequena instância tinha tensas
o japão morreu pra floripa pra
florianópolis vão morrer na beira da
praia
vou lá ficar junto de deus meus filhos
os filhos dele moravam aqui é e morava
na beira da praia surfistas e quando vou
para lá então eu vou ter uma vista
bonita nessa minha peça nesse meu
período de espera até encarar outro de
falta ele apareceu em florianópolis
e lá no centro de reabilitação cardíaca
que foi criado na universidade do estado
de santa catarina é o núcleo de carne
hoje ms no exercício que se propõe a
atender pessoas usando como recurso
principal a promoção
saúde não somente prevenção mas
tratamento o exercício físico e se
tornou também um grupo de pesquisa não
se é um grupo de pesquisa vinculada cnpq
ante desenvolve projetos mostrando a
importância do exercício como recurso de
prevenção de tratamento e de fato estava
muito cansado quer dizer mal andava
tinha falta de ar mas disciplinado e
acreditou no exercício
como eu já acreditava que eu acredito
cada vez mais o exercício uma
terapêutica é impressionante
para reverter as expectativas sombrias
com a canetinha
ou seja quem tem ser cardíaca tinha e
grave como ele tinha faz parte de um
grupo com expectativa sombria de vida já
que 50% de mortalidade anual
então o que falaram para ele tinha a ver
o que não tinha a ver que não tinha
possibilidade de reverter isso
ele acreditou nessa possibilidade cada
dia conseguia caminhar um pouco mais em
pouco tempo ele já tava e chegou aqui os
69 já estava caminhando 23 km sem
precisar parar passou a fazer exercícios
resistidos musculação melhorou a
aparência melhorou a autoestima era um
sujeito elegante começou a a a viver
bons momentos na vida melhorou muito a
qualidade de vida desde a quinta-feira
nobre isso chegando aos 71 em
determinado dia já estava com 73 74 anos
encontrou comigo lá na universidade e
perguntou se podia voltar a surfar
eu não entendi muito bem foi o que
surfar
eu já fui surfista na década de 60 e
meus filhos são surfistas
vou para a praia fico lá na beira da
praia vendo eles o fae da vontade
popular sem ter que fazer pode veja
alguns anos eu estava na marca do
pênalti literalmente já tá com a
sobrevida interessante vendo bem será
que vale a pena encarar a água fria
ondas grandes é não você é um surfista
diferente eu vou entrar na água quando
estiver quente grande onda preta
falei estou acreditando em você uma boa
taxa já que você faz questão
vamos encarar é assim de fato ele ou ele
mostrou a fotografia dizendo que era
surfista na década de 60 em são paulo e
passou a surfar em florianópolis e não
contente com isso entrou no circuito
catarinense de ser para todas as etapas
entre 70 e 80 anos só tinha ele mas ele
era um sujeito único e com isso ganhou
espaço na mídia nacional apareceu num
programa de esportes de veiculação
nacional no esporte duas vezes enfim se
tornou a figura conhecida e surfando e
vivendo cada vez melhor
tinha recair ajustável medicamento dele
quem tem uma doença como a dele usa
muitos medicamentos dava ajustado o
mesmo diurético diminui direto com o
mundo um pouco determinado remédio que
as artérias enfim mas foi seguindo a
vida e isso chegou próximo dos 80 anos
para quem ia morrer antes dos 70 bater
nos 80 anos foi um espetáculo pra rever
muita coisa né teve dez anos para rever
a vida pra fatah começar a fazer o que
era importante para ele de fato ele fez
isso e imuno morreu surfando fique
tranquilo morreu dormindo acordou morto
como se diz
isso mostra que às vezes pois é
dependendo de como a gente dorme e de
como a gente sonha parece que dormir às
vezes é mais perigoso que enfrentar
ondas grandes e água fria e tetra e até
tubarão por perto e nessa situação eu
vou começar a falar um pouco de mim
também é bom fazer essa ligação falei
que essa história tem muito a ver comigo
tem eu não sou médico cromada muito
tempo teve oportunidade de ter duas
vidas espero ter três vidas numa vida só
a minha primeira vida profissional foi
em são paulo
trabalhei 16 anos vivenciando uma
medicina bem convencional eu trabalhava
em grandes hospitais trabalhei no bom
tempo
as clínicas do começo do icó e fazendo o
cateterismo cardíaco e hemodinâmico
acompanhando a intervenção de perto a
cirurgia de perto
enfim vive uma fase muito boa em são
paulo aprendendo muito mais vivendo uma
medicina convencional seja na
cardiologia seja na uti trabalhei muito
tempo na uti e um grande hospital de são
paulo pelo servidor iii naquela época
ainda desde o início da minha atividade
eu questionava muito certas intervenções
porque a medicina brasileira assim como
a medicina que acontece em grande parte
do mundo ocidental
a medicina que eu acho excessivamente
agressiva ou seja se preocupou muito em
atacar os efeitos do problema e não vai
nas causas do problema
sedentarismo por exemplo uma grande
causa de morte precoce não somente por
doenças cardiovasculares está
relacionado com o surgimento de escolas
da cidade mas por câncer sets e um
estilo de vida muito importante e nem
sempre existia esse ataque adequado no
meu modo de ver a doença que removendo
causas e ficavam cantando é feito isso
gere a progênie há muitos procedimentos
de forte emoção e desnecessários que
poderiam ser postergados no mínimo e
batendo nos 40 anos resolvi procurar
melhor qualidade de vida pra mim para
minha família
14 filhos né vim com a mulher e quatro
filhos para florianópolis e cheguei aqui
e tive a possibilidade de começar a
exercer inclusive a medicina diferente
do que eu faço em são paulo até porque
não tinha espaço para fazer o que eu
consegui fazer aqui
ou seja fazer o que preconiza a
organização mundial de saúde por exemplo
outras entidades importantes que é
promover saúde de fato que pensar é como
cardiologista como médico não ficar
pensando só em baixa pressão ou os 11
tupi artéria mas atacar as causas do
problema promover saúde de fato que é
uma questão muito mais ampla a questão
de bem estar novamente físico de ter
pessoa normal e conhecerá um pouco mais
baixo mas é uma questão de bem estar na
vida de modo geral bem estar físico
mental social enfim significa viver com
boa qualidade de vida e tempo a
qualidade de vida
com um parâmetro importante para saber
se eu estava procedendo certo ou não
a minha proposta de promoção de saúde de
tratamento de doenças como hipertensão
arterial doença coronariana e centro e
nessa situação da minha vida recomeçou
na uma nova vida que é começou recomeçou
aos 40 anos e nessa situação o papa
voltou passa eu tive possibilidade de me
tornar professor é são paulo era um
médico que vive em ambiente
universitário todas as clínicas da usp
todo servidor que as residências de
medição do brasil não somente de de
clínica de cardiologia defende várias
personalidades mas não era um professor
ruim e eventualmente fazer uma palestra
de 60 mas paralelamente são paulo tendo
uma formação paralela em medicina do
exercício e fiz medicina do exercício e
do esporte na usp
a fã da educação física especializado em
fisiologia do exercício da escola
paulista de medicina e aqui pra nós e
pôde aplicar isso me tornando o
professor é criando programas de
prevenção e reabilitação que como é o
costume dizer significa uma medicina uma
prática que não se ensina na escola
infelizmente não estamos num país que
qualquer cidade de porte médio têm é é
tratamento intervencionista tem
cateterismo e angioplastia de 60 mas
muitas capitais brasileiras não têm
sequer um programa de reabilitação ou
seja tem o que é passa a ser algo que
eventual proposta de tratamento de
combate à doença mas não tem o que o que
é básico que é fundamental que é o
tratamento atacando causa isso eu pude
começar a fazer aqui
e nessa situação uma das coisas que eu
tenha avaliado é doença cardiovascular
de função sexual que caminham juntos
aqui é o trabalho que mostra que tem
disfunção erétil para homens mas isso
vale para mulheres também quando têm
disfunção sexual
significa ter um preditor de risco para
doença cardiovascular
a morte precoce não somente porque esse
é o drama por todas as causas câncer por
exemplo então é algo que deve ser
avaliado em cada consulta com o clínico
do imó lojista do cardiologista porque
perdi isso e quanto mais grave foi a
função maior é o risco é então essa é
uma questão importante tão juntos a
pressão quanto mais alta for maior a
chance de que a disfunção sexual em
homens e mulheres porque disfunção
sexual tem a ver com circulação
o exercício físico houve uma série de
benefícios para o organismo ajuda a
tratar diabetes prevenir é um tratamento
obrigatório por gilberto é um tratamento
obrigatório para doenças
cardiovasculares como hipertensão
doenças coronarianas yessica dia que eu
já mostrei o caso aí o resultado que
pode porque pode acontecer às custas de
exercícios reduz a mortalidade do grupo
mais grave que significa dizer que
apenas um ano e 50%
o exercício é muito importante e nesse
caso é da opção sexual ele tem um papel
importante que é esse da função de o
telhar ainda teve uma camada interna das
artérias que ao mesmo tempo é uma
barreira para que o conheceram no passe
pro parede da artéria inflame
iniciativas carozzi placas que vão
entupir com várias artérias que vão
perceber certo mas é uma grande grande
lula e uma substância que ele produz
estimulado pelo exercício óxido nítrico
é um potente vasodilatador é o mais
potente vasodilatador que a gente
conhece o que é produzido pelo adultério
e e e o dadá produz tanto crédito quanto
exercício ou seja é uma ação que supera
a ação dos medicamentos facilitadores da
função sexual que na versão masculina
por exemplo isso o exercício proporciona
isso a gente vem estudando e fazem
entender por que esse é um trabalho que
eu apresentei no congresso mundial de
tecnologia em melbourne
mostrando que para idosos com
insuficiência cardíaca e com o nível
baixo pessoa ser hora limite inferior a
uma baixa normal
é a gente de forma aleatória é é é
avaliou dois grupos ambos submetidos a
exercício intenso entre valados programa
de exercício
para tratamento é que nem qualquer
treinamento físico visa progressão hoare
é um exemplo disso
quem pode andar rápido o tempo que andar
devagar quem pode começar a correr não
tem pra ficar só andando quem vai
levantar mais peso para levantar mais
peso e significa progressão e alguns
chegam a surfar como ali chegou depois
de ter saído de uma situação crítica
então a lógica é a progressão ea gente
tem usado exercício intenso intervalado
como se faz em academia para jovens hoje
em dia e nesse estudo que observou que
ambos os grupos exercício exclusivo
exercício na terceirona melhorou muito a
condição pulmonar a condição aeróbica
obtida pelo consumo de oxigênio e
melhoraram muito a função sexual
a função erétil e esse grupo apresenta
uma grande prevalência solução e médio
a única diferença foi o nível de
testosterona no sangue aumentou em que
usou obviamente mas sem vantagem sem
benefício adicional
a mostra ocupa a importância do
exercício nesse aspecto de reverter o
processo de envelhecimento já que em
sentença cardíaca significa alguém
envelhecido precocemente que perdeu
massa muscular perdeu disposição perdeu
vigor perdeu energia para viver
a gente vem espírito da dança como uma
possibilidade de treinamento não fica só
no exercício convencional adams aumento
do batimento cardíaco tanto quanto
exercício convencional
quem tá dançando atingir batimento
cardíaco semelhante é o que obtém quando
também esteja ocorrendo na rua ea dança
baixa pressão como exercício
convencional e com vantagens adicionais
porque obviamente o exercício mecânico
em cima do esteira é algo que
proporciona muito bem difícil mas é o
que não permite uma visão uma aderência
tão boa programação de exercícios ea
dança facilita os nossos pacientes do
programa de reabilitação que se
exercitam meio da dança não falta aulas
três vezes por semana lá isso se torna
um hobby passa a fazer isso no final de
semana também que a dança possibilita
algo mais contato de pessoas a
aproximação de pessoas e freqüentemente
depois da dança rola alguma coisa mais
né isso a gente observa e tanto que um
ponto de vista que eu defendi nesse
artigo o saque do brasileiro que hoje se
que o padrão ouro para tratar a doença
cardiovascular função sexual mesmo tempo
ea dança e ia se explicar por que esse é
um trabalho que o último estudo que
mostra que mostra um estudo jonata mais
um pesquisador americano que mostra que
é o grupo de baixa aptidão física então
decidi divididos em 15 de acordo com a
capacidade de exercício apresentou uma
alta taxa de mortalidade no decorrer do
estudo de técnicas de estudo prospectivo
sem diferença entre quem tinha doença
cardíaca em barra branca e quem era
aparentemente saudável e o grupo de
excelente aptidão física de boa
capacidade de treinamento físico
apresentou uma baixíssima taxa de
mortalidade no decorrer do tempo mais
uma vez sem diferença em quem era doente
e quem não era
mostrando que talvez mais importante do
que ficar procurando controlar entupidas
saber como é que a pessoa está vivendo
esse tá fazendo exercício está se
mantendo bem disposto e para encerrar a
mostra essas fotografias do grupo d de
pacientes que iniciou a reabilitação foi
um exercício convencional passou a fazer
exercício dançando
isso tornou um hobby e aqui já se tornou
uma manifestação artística estão
participando do festival de dança no cic
ocorrendo inclusive com grupos de dança
mais jovens mostrando que a dança é
muito poderosa
acredite nela procure dançando no final
de semana que vai a pé
muito obrigado pela sugestão de defesa
[Aplausos]